devops is a collaborative approach just
taken up by most companies these days it
focuses on scaling up and making the
entire process of scaling up much
smoother so no doubt companies are
actively looking out for devops
engineers welcome to another tutorial
with simply learn I'm Lance and today
we'll be looking at how you can become a
devops engineer so let's begin
so by definition devops is a
collaboration between the development
and the operations team which enables
continuous delivery of application and
services to the end users so let's
expand on this definition first the
development team is the one that
actually produces the products the
operations team is related with the
management or the maintenance of these
products now there's a link that devops
forms between these two teams which
makes this entire process much smoother
and this approach this collaborative
approach is what's called devops so
devops focuses on continuous delivery of
application which means that when the
development team is ready with the
product it immediately goes into the
maintenance or the management phase and
it's then pushed onto the end users with
minimum delay now just in case you doubt
the stand of devops today or its growth
in the near future you must know that
according to the information week devops
will be in high demand for upcoming
years and has no chance of slowing down
also according to LinkedIn over the past
few years devops has increased in demand
by 50 percent now that's quite a lot of
growth so clearly devops is a field that
will be great to dive into and grow in
so before we begin how you can actually
become a devops engineer let's look at
what we'll be going through in this
video first we look at who is a devops
engineer followed by the devops career
roadmap we'll then look into a devops
certification and then finally the
salary trends for a devops engineer so
who is a devops engineer now a devops
engineer is an I.T professional who
understands the software development
lifecycle and when I say software
development lifecycle I did not just
mean the devops approach but right from
a waterfall model which is a traditional
software development life cycle and then
as you know we moved on to the agile and
then we finally reached the devops
lifecycle so a devops engineer needs to
understand the whole purpose of the this
life cycle why are we heading to move
from one model to the other what are the
shortcomings that the previous models
had and what all does devops make up for
also other than understanding this
entire process they also need to know
how to use the various automation tools
for developing The Continuous
integration and continuous deployment
pipelines so of course your next
question must be what is the continuous
integration and continuous deployment
pipeline well as you can see on your
right we have an image of this pipeline
so there are various stages so first you
have your planning stage where you plan
things out and write an algorithm for
your product then it's the building
stage where the algorithm actually
transforms into a code and is a product
which could be used then you have the
testing stage in the testing stage your
product is tested all the bugs are
caught and all of this is corrected and
once all of that's done it's then sent
to the deployment stage which means now
your product is ready to be deployed
once it's deployed of course a product
needs continuous monitoring this is now
something new which has been introduced
into the devops lifecycle that although
your product is out in D now the
monitoring stage is something that the
devops approach focuses on much more
than our previous models and for very
good reason which is that once your
product is deployed into the real world
to ensure customer satisfaction it's
important that you continuously monitor
the product this way you're able to
catch the bugs fix them and push it back
to the clients and ensure that they are
happy with your product and would go for
it again now in simple words a devops
engineer is expected to collaborate with
the developers and the operations team
to deliver high quality products within
a minimum amount of time now devops
engineer as such is not a profile that
you might come across very often but of
course there are a number of career
paths that you can undertake under the
devops engineer but of course there are
a number of career paths under a devops
engineer now some of these are the
devops architect automation engineer
software tester integration specialist
security engineer and release manager
now let's look at the devops career
roadmap so basically if you are looking
forward to bagging that devops engineer
job where should you start and how
should you go about it well first things
first there are a few programming
languages which go hand in hand with the
devops tools you need to pick up these
and also know the Linux fundamentals
devops uses these programming languages
for developing and automating software
now the three most common languages used
with the devops tools are Ruby Python
and JavaScript it is always advised that
you know at least one of these and of
course we must consider the fact that
these three languages are used with
completely different tools so knowing
just one of these languages does not
mean that you can now work with any tool
under the devops approach but it does
give you a good hang of at least one of
them which is more than most can say
it's also important to know the
fundamentals of the Linux command line
interface of course this is not very
unique to devops whichever career path
you are choosing Linux fundamentals is
one of the most important things now
let's discuss some of the mandatory
Linux skills that of devops Engineers
should be aware of first is of course
the Linux shell now you must either know
bash or the kernel shell then it's the
Linux commands now there are a huge
number of Linux commands but the basic
ones you must know no matter what are
the find graph up Arc and the set
command and finally we have the
networking commands in slookup which is
for querying the DNS and netstat from
monitoring your connections our next
Milestone would be learning the source
code management now source code
management is especially important when
you're dealing with huge projects so
that all your code irrespective of the
number of files you have or the number
of versions of a particular code you
have everything is organized and can be
easily accessible so it's important that
you're comfortable with at least one of
the source code management tools here
the most common ones we see are get CVS
and Mercurial I would personally
recommend you to choose git and why git
because git is used to track changes in
the source code it can manage large
projects efficiently and it allows
multiple developers to work together
with grade ease now our next stage is to
learn to build applications so a devops
engineer must know how to build an
application and commit to the source
code management tools such as git now a
popular tool used to build applications
which makes things much simpler is Maven
why Maven well it supports parallel
builds instant access to new features
without any additional configuration and
has an easy build process
now Maven is actually an automation tool
which helps to build and manage software
projects within a short period of time
so here you have the bomb file which is
required to build an application under
which you have a set of jars you have
the commands which are to be executed
the builds plugins and the builds
profile but in order to automate the
entire process you require a continuous
integration or a continuous development
tool and this brings us to our fourth
stage which is learning to automate the
process using CI and CD tools one of the
most extensively used tools in this
field is Jenkins Jenkins is an open
source continuous integration tool it
helps to automate continuous development
testing and deployment of newly created
codes well why Jenkins well because it
has multiple plugins it is easily
distributed across multiple machines and
has an easy installation and
configuration process our next stage is
to learn to test the applications once
you have completed the build process
learn how to automate the testing
process of web applications
one of the best testing tools for QA
teams is selenium and why selenium above
all the other tools that provide the
same functionality well because it
provides fast execution allows scripting
in several languages and also supports
parallel test execution the next thing
is to learn to deploy applications in
production servers so you should learn
how to deploy and run the applications
in the production servers and in order
to deploy an application you should have
the knowledge of containers such as
Docker and configuration management
tools like ansible
so Docker helps with the
containerization while configuration
management tools such as ansible helps
provide you the capability of pushing
configurations onto multiple servers and
maintaining them in the required state
so why choose Docker while high
scalability and efficiency reusable data
volumes isolated applications and why
ansible because unlike other tools in
this field it has a push-based
configuration it is agentless and uses
SSH for secure connections the next
stage is to learn to monitor the
applications so monitoring your
applications is another important aspect
of a devops engineer in this stage we
identify the issue and implement the
changes as quickly as possible the most
popular tool which provides for
monitoring applications is nagios it has
a comprehensive monitoring system high
availability and immediate remediation
and finally a devops engineer must know
the working of cloud providers for a
devops engineer it's important to know
about the cloud service providers and
their base 6. cloud computing is an
important skill to learn irrespective of
which field you're in today as a lot of
companies have the infrastructure on the
cloud Amazon web services is the most
popular cloud provider whereas Microsoft
Azure and Google Cloud platform are
slowly catching up to Amazon Amazon web
services provides high scalability and
flexibility is cost effective and
provides better security
let's now look at some of the devops
certifications you can opt for the first
one is the AWS certified devops Engineer
program which is offered by Amazon web
services and then of course we have the
devops certification training offered by
our very own simply learn simply learn
also provides programs which are more
specific to tools such as Chef puppet
ansible and selenium certification and
we also provide a devops architect
Masters program
so now these are some of the most
popular certifications available in the
market
if you're taking up a career you must
know what kind of salary to expect an
average salary of a devops engineer in
the United States is 115
666 dollars per year so this is the
average salary as you can see here guys
there's a graph which shows how there's
been a growth and this graph here will
give you a good idea of the salary Trend
an average salary of a devops engineer
in India on the other hand is six lakh
12 000 per year so again here we have a
graph on the right which demonstrates
the pattern and growth in the salary now
here's some additional material to
prepare yourself and help you in the
journey to becoming a devops engineer so
this is simply learn's YouTube playlist
on devops as you can see here are a
number of videos you can start off with
this fun short video on what is devops
it introduces devops to you in the most
basic and fun way possible and then you
have devops tutorial for beginners what
is devops another tutorial introduction
to devops and then you can follow this
up with the tutorials on the various
tools under devops for example there's
git there's Jenkins Docker Docker swarm
ansible Chef puppet a comparison between
the various configuration management
tools and there are also devops
interview questions part one and part
two which will help you prepare for your
interviews now why devops is better than
agile or if it's the other way around
watch this video to find out how to
create your resume for the post of a
devops engineer and so on so there are a
lot of videos here guys you can
definitely go through them and it
provides you with a lot of information
not only that before you actually take
up the simply learn course to get a
better understanding of the kind of
content and the quality of content that
they offer you can come back here and
check out their free courses or their
free tutorial videos and with that we
come to an end of this video I hope you
all enjoyed it and I hope it was really
helpful for all those who are aspiring
to become a devops engineer
please hit the like button if so also
share our video And subscribe to our
Channel if you haven't yet because we
have a lot more coming up for you so
thank you all and see you all next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here